[Music]
could you speak to slow productivity
and
you know perhaps you could could speak
to
john griffin's book the scientists you
mentioned a bunch of scientists earlier
in this conversation
because you you strike me also as kind
of a proof case
or a test case
of slow productivity in a world where it
is
thought by and large to not be possible
or to just be outdated so could you
just expand on that in any way that
makes sense to you well i mean i'll tell
you and this is literally true
what i was doing in the moments before
we logged on to this discussion right
now it was in the other room in my
offices here with a notebook
working on slow productivity notes on
slow productivity because i'm thinking
about maybe writing a book on it but i'm
still in the earlier stages and i had
gone for a walk earlier and had been
developing some new thoughts and i
wanted to get them down so i was
actually pretty frantically
taking notes in my notebook uh as i was
like looking at the clock like i got to
get into to talk to tim so when i say
it's fresh on my mind i mean it's
literally fresh in my mind and so
that's a big caveat that means this is
not a fully baked idea when it's i love
half-baked ideas yeah so the ingredients
are swirling
so here i'll pitch you what i wrote down
an hour ago
so as of an hour ago
this is the way because i what i do when
i'm thinking about ideas is i try to
basically
re re-pitch them out from scratch and i
do that again and again and and each
time i do it there's overlap with the
previous times but also new pieces and
that's how it polishes it's why it takes
me six months to a year to get for
example a book idea
ready to even propose like it's just
this is the like we talked about the
math mind like i need the pieces to make
sense
so my my current take on slow
productivity is
the problem itself so here's the problem
we're facing
the human brain is wired to it's it's
good at making a plan for executing
something that you think is important
and it makes you feel good when you
complete that plan
this is critical to humans why we're
different than a lot of animals we can
we can actually come up with a plan to
do something and feel motivation to do
it and feel good when we actually you
know we need to fix the fence we fix the
fence the cattle can't get out we feel
really good
the issue is
if you don't do anything let's say i'm
not making any plans i don't want to do
anything we know that makes you feel
terrible so you take away people's
autonomy their their sense of efficacy
and they're miserable we know that
but if you put too much on people's
plates so that now you have more on your
plate more obligations to which you have
some sort of ascent to complete then you
can easily conceive actually all getting
done
you short circuit that drive
just like your drive for hunger is
really important but if you eat like a
huge amount of junk food it short
circuits to drive and you end up
unhealthy so when we have way too much
on our plate more than we can easily
imagine how it's going to get done
it makes us really unhappy because we're
short-circuiting a cognitive drive here
and we get sort of anxious and
overwhelmed and it doesn't feel good
and so we can't treat humans like we
would a computer processor when a
computer processor you want to pipeline
as many instructions as possible that
are sitting there so that not a single
cycle is wasted because you just want to
make sure that you always have something
to do but for the human brain
that huge pipeline of things that are
waiting to be done actually makes the
brain unhappy right
and so our
solution to this type of overload we
have too much on our plate in work and
in our life admin as well our solution
has been to
use fast productivity so fast
productivity are like tactics and
systems for increasing the amount of
things you finish on the scale of days
and weeks so how do i get more stuff
this is what all productivity software
is about lower friction easier access to
information take out seven steps in the
process of getting this meeting
scheduled we want to maximize the number
of things we can execute on the scales
of days and weeks
my emerging concept of slow productivity
says
shift that scale up to years months and
years
i want to maximize the amount of
meaningful stuff i get done in the next
five years
it completely changes the game in a way
that becomes very compatible with the
human brain
because now suddenly
while i'm going to try to do a lot less
the stuff i'm doing i'm doing it on a
larger time scale so maybe i'm working a
lot on it this week and then i go a
month without doing it at all and i have
a hard day today and an off day tomorrow
you have the seasonality up and down
rhythms which is a better fit for the
human brain
you get rid of the sense of overload
because if you want to produce you know
a good book in the next two years
that's a very different set of
initiatives than i want to do as many
writerly related promotional things as
possible this week like that ladder
could be a real source of stress and
overload the former can be a real source
of fulfillment and you you tend to
produce things of higher value because
when you're just focusing on
maximizing what you can do in the scale
of days or weeks
it diverts the sustained application of
energy and attention needed to actually
do the things that move the needle or
that you're proud of and so
i think it's a real issue
i think in the workplace we have to
completely rethink
work allocation our current mode of
doing this is completely incompatible
with slow productivity we basically just
throw an unlimited amount of work at
individuals and say it's up to you to
self-regulate
it's like an impossible task to ask and
so you know i had this new yorker piece
recently called why do we work too much
and i sort of make this argument in
there that if we have to self-regulate
we're just going to end up with 20 too
much on our plate we're going to let
stress be the feedback function that
slows us down and in our personal lives
we probably
need to be doing significantly less but
the stuff we're doing do it better and
over longer time periods so
there's just this fundamental mismatch
with our brain that's happening right
now that this this epidemic of busyness
i think is causing issues
because of its mismatch with our brain
and maybe something like slow
productivity is the way out of it
you